when I look around that's what other
teams are doing and trying to do to find
their head coach if Jason Garrett had
been out on the market two weeks ago he
would have had five offers for head
coaching I know that so you've got to
look at what your alternative is that's
Jerry Jones on 105 three the fan on
Tuesday popping up his head coach Jason
Garrett by claiming that if Garrett had
been available there would be five
offers for his services and Chris I
throw your challenge flag on that I've
been saying that a lot lately you know
you say for the last two years and it
finally sticks so I'm throwing the
challenge flag on Jerry Jones here's why
yeah four years ago after the notorious
Dez caught it game Jason Garrett became
a free agent and nobody else offered him
a job
everybody knew his contract was expiring
at the end of the season the season
ended after the divisional round and it
was just really cowboys he didn't want
to leave but no one came after him so I
don't buy this idea that five teams
would have wanted him if anything
Garrett is viewed almost like a Mike
McCarthy where the offense is too
inflexible there's no creativity there's
no adjustments we heard the stories and
Jerry Jones confirmed yesterday that
they had the code cracked as it relates
to their defensive alignment and that
all goes back to coaching so I don't buy
that five teams would have wanted them
and all due respect I'm not sure anyone
would happen yeah I mean I respect Jerry
Jones loyalty to Jason Garrett but I
mean I'm with you there I mean that
that's that's BS I'm throwing the
challenge flag on that as well I mean
well five teams after Jason Garrett
that's ridiculousness say maybe there
have been a team that would have danced
and flirted with him but yeah I think
you're Mike McCarthy comparison is very
fair to where fan bases would have been
like really we're gonna bring this guy
in and you know he's only won two
playoff games and all those things when
it came up and yeah I'm not buying it
all right now during that same interview
and as a response to what Jerry Jones
said regarding the desirability that
would apply to Jason Garrett Jones was
asked for the record what this means for
the future of Jason Garrett in Dallas
here's what Jones had to say listen very
carefully why would I put
some kind of statement out that says
this is what we're going to do when we
might have an opportunity here next week
this at the time when these things are
thought about this is the time when they
are chewed on this is the time when you
may see an opportunity next week you
didn't know existed this week in the
area of personnel or in the area of
coaching and I'm not trying to be cute
here I'm just saying that one of the
advantages that we have is that we can
operate with that kind of flexibility
Jerry's not trying to be cute your hand
unless they are in the process of
cloning Sean McVeigh and the experiment
won't be over until next week like what
other circumstance changes from this
week to next week
here's what changes coaches who are
currently employed and you know working
become available when their seasons end
and this isn't an assistant coach this
is the long rumored connection between
and there is a real friendship between
Jerry Jones and Sean Payton and there's
been plenty of speculation about Sean
Payton's future and and I look I don't I
know that Sean Payton has has been upset
in the past when people will throw his
name out there is potentially leaving
New Orleans but Jones is the one who's
essentially thrown his name out there
because that's who he's talking about
Chris that's the opportunity that may be
there next week if the Saints lose to
the Rams on Sunday all of a sudden
here's Sean Payton I mean why else would
you not say of course Jason Garrett's
our head coach because there is a chance
with the bird in the hand to hold on to
that burden hand just for a week because
the two in the bush may be available in
the form of Sean Payton yeah I mean when
I heard the quote that's exactly what I
thought of as well I mean when he said
there might be an opportunity next week
as in if the Saints lose to the Rams
there might be this coach that's maybe
looking to change sides I mean I you
know I guess yes he's well we've always
like you said have heard rumors of Sean
Payton and the relationship with the
Dallas Cowboys and he had worked there
before and the Dallas Cowboys is always
one of those bright new sh r and bright
shiny objects that any head coach is
like wow it would be pretty cool to be
the head coach of America's team they
certainly do have their own aura and you
know fan base all around the
country so I find it hard to believe
that Sean Payton would leave New Orleans
right now because they are built to be
back in this same position next year but
at one of these in one of these years
he's probably gonna be thinking all
right this has got to be drew breezes
last year or maybe I need to get out of
Dodge at some point so I'm with you and
I kind of thought the same thing but I
just can't imagine Sean Payton leaving
the Saints right now after some of the
struggles they've had and now he's built
them up to be a perennial Super Bowl
contender really right now and he's got
the organization right where he wants it
I agree with you but from Jerry Jones
perspective he must think it's
sufficiently real or at least the door
is cracked a little bit that maybe after
this week maybe maybe Brees does walk
away who knows but here's the other
factor that I think is is swirling
around in Jerry Jones mind yeah he
better be ready to jump on Sean Payton
before Sean Payton gets jumped on by the
Browns because I think that is something
to be to be keeping an eye on in the
future and I think they decided to keep
Freddie kitchens because look it worked
well last year let's see how it plays
out if it doesn't work we can always
hire somebody else and maybe the door
opens for Peyton in Cleveland before
Jerry has a chance to yank him through
the door to Dallas so you know hey Jerry
aggressive businessman and he knows what
he wants and he goes and gets it he
throws whatever money on the table is
necessary to get Sean Payton to bite and
now good luck complying with the Rooney
rule and Jerry Jones went down this road
15 years ago when he hired Bill Parcells
and and did a phone interview of Dennis
green just so he could check the box and
the league said you can't do phone
interviews in the future it has to be in
person but but if everyone will know
what he's doing if he fires Jason
Garrett next week if the Saints lose on
Sunday because he essentially said it
yesterday without saying it yeah well I
mean I don't know I mean is he looking
at an Eric be enemy is there an
assistant that maybe we're missing I'm
just throwing you know food for thought
out there but obviously yes he's not
making this statement they are in
evaluation mode as far as where they
want to see the future of their
organization going and he hasn't given
Jason Garrett that last stamp of
approval to say you're here and you're
the guy for the next few years or
whatever it may be and they are thinking
about it the Jones family's having some
meetings
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports